Wednesday has been the talk of TV
Twitter lately but not always for a good
reason so what's really going on with
the sudden Tim Burton backlash after
debuting on November 23rd the Netflix
series managed to rack up positive
reviews and record-breaking streaming
numbers with more than 341 million hours
watched in its first week on the app
according to Netflix no other English
language TV show has been able to bring
in those results for the streamer over
the course of its first week the
Supernatural coming-of-age story follows
Jenna Ortega's Wednesday Adams as she
adjusts to life at Nevermore Academy a
vermont-based reform school for other
peculiar outcasts like herself in the
fictional town of Jericho on the surface
Wednesday is a show that seems innocent
and fun with a familiar premise based on
The Adams Family characters and
franchise however there's something that
many fans have found extremely wrong
with the spin-off which is getting
talked about a lot as of late for some
Wednesday viewers it feels like the
creative team including executive
producer and director Tim Burton chose
to cast Black actors as the show's main
antagonists as a result fans have been
taken to social media to voice their
outrage one user tweeted I really wanted
to like Wednesday but I think it's
unforgivable that all the black
characters are either bullies or morally
compromised and why is Wednesday hostile
towards them WTF what kind of ridiculous
writing is this
the casting choices that viewers are
most upset about are new york-born actor
Joy Sunday who plays resident mean girl
Bianca Barclay at Nevermore and
Hollywood newcomer Iman Marson who plays
Lucas Walker a local bully Walker's
family runs the show's fictional Pilgrim
World his father Noble Walker is the
mayor of Jericho and owns the
colonizer-themed theme park
it takes a special kind of stupid to
devote an entire theme park to sell it's
responsible for Mass genocide
it's easy to see how casting black
actors to run such a place could be
considered tone deaf which is exactly
what people are calling it on social
media self-described anti-racism
consultant John Cornejo tweeted a black
mayor who owns a museum celebrating
pilgrims and colonizers in Wednesday is
really wild for me I am so tired of
characters that are played by black
actors but written as white where the
director has done nothing with how their
Blackness would have impacted their
journey and role in society this
colorblind approach is not the one a
lack of diversity in Tim Burton's
projects has been an issue over the
years after making the 2016 fantasy
flick Miss Peregrine's Home for Peculiar
Children Burton was called out for
having a predominantly white cast with
Samuel L Jackson being one of the only
non-white stars and serving as an
antagonist Burton told bustle at the
time things either call for things or
they don't I remember back when I was a
child watching The Brady Bunch and they
started to get all politically correct
like okay let's have an Asian child and
a black I used to get more offended by
that
Jackson himself called out Burton for
his lack of diversity telling bustle
I had to go back in my head and go how
many black characters have been in Tim
Burton movies and I may have been the
first
[Music]